they fled their homes for safety
leaving behind all their belongings not
knowing if they will ever return to live
there or find a pile of rubble instead
for some the loss is immense
my wife children and i all sitting in
the same room
we have three children one is a
nine-month-old baby
all of a sudden the house was hit we
couldn't get out
then came another strike and the house
crumbled over us
they were trapped under the rubble i
started screaming
but couldn't find them the ambulances
could not reach the area for about an
hour but it was too late my wife and
three children
died
[Music]
his is a story that has become all too
common in gaza
this video shows people running for
their lives after a multi-story building
was hit in central gaza on monday
people visibly shaken shocked and in
fear
israel says it targets buildings used by
hamas or other armed groups
claims that often go unproven sometimes
residents are warned to evacuate the
premises by a roof knock
which amounts to an initial small
explosion indicating that
israeli forces are planning to destroy
the building
but warning shots or not the suffering
caused to civilians living there
is untold
gaza-based journalist yumna syed
narrowly escaped death
when a car in front of her was targeted
in broad daylight
without prior notice of there were four
people in the car three
of them came out in pieces embattled
prime minister netanyahu has warned that
the fighting will continue
in full force and it will take time
the united nations relief and works
agency has opened
50 schools across the gaza strip for
palestinians seeking refuge
tens of thousands of people are already
sheltered there
crammed in the classrooms
it's not only the war we have to be
careful of the coronavirus
how can we protect ourselves and our
children
the un agency is expecting more people
to come
it's the blue color and the blue flag
makes it more secure than their
own home i think at the moment nowhere
in gaza is secure
but hopefully all actors involved in the
fighting will respect the blue color of
the united nations
but safety here is not guaranteed during
the 2014 war
several u.n facilities were shelled 44
people were killed
including 10 staff abdul hamid
al-jazeera in west jerusalem